silent movie references political satire
conveniently timed lightning strikes
here are a few things about the 1985
sci-fi classic back to the future that
you'll only notice after watching it
multiple times
a lot of the foreshadowing in back to
the future isn't exactly subtle but some
bits are easier to miss than others for
example when marty mcfly worries about
sending out his audition tape in the
film's opening moments he speculates
about the record company telling him he
has no future sure enough he almost
doesn't if you look at some of these
early moments long enough you find out
how layered they really are especially
once you know the course that the movie
is going to take in the scene where
principal strickland scolds marty for
being a slacker it's easy to notice that
he says that history's gonna change but
he also identifies george mcfly's lack
of drive or lack of backbone really as
the reason marty's father never amounted
to anything sure enough that turns out
to be the exact part of history that
changes
it's always been obvious that the last
few minutes of back to the future serve
to set up the plot of part two but
there's one bit of sequel bait that only
gets a double take once you already know
what'll happen when marty gets to 2015.
right before the libyan nationalists
crash the party doc brown mentions his
high-minded time travel goals i've
always dreamed of seeing the future
looking beyond my ears
seeing the progress of mankind
very noble and inspiring indeed but then
he adds something that most of us would
probably find even more inspiring i'll
also be able to see who wins the next 25
world series
it's a fine joke but it's a lot more
foreboding in the context of biff's use
of the sports almanac of film later plus
it makes doc's outrage about marty's
identical idea for a money-making scheme
in part two kind of hypocritical then
again the doku gleefully hoped to learn
the world series winners isn't really
the same doc who scolded marty for
besmirching the nobility of time travel
maybe the extra 30 years he had to
speculate on probable consequences or
able to change his mind if you're a fan
of silent comedies few images are as
iconic as poor harold lloyd dangling
from the hand of an enormous clock in
1923's safety last if you know the film
or even just the shot it's impossible
not to see the resemblance when doc
brown finds himself hanging for dear
life from the hour hand it's a great
homage especially when you remember that
doc is played by yet another albeit
unrelated lloyd christopher this time
lloyds of the world should probably all
stay away from clock towers just in case
back to the future isn't content with
just one reference to safety last though
it sneaks in a second one that doubles
as foreshadowing for doc's later bit of
aerial comedy in the film's opening as
the camera pans over doc's clock
collection we see that one of the clocks
has a tiny figurine of harold lloyd
attached to one of the hands we take it
to doc brown as a fan of safety last
himself
no one turns on a classic time travel
caper to see a small town mayoral race
but you still shouldn't miss this
cynical joke about the cyclical nature
of politics in marty's original 1985
timeline mayor goldy wilson is running
for re-election and the megaphones
installed on his campaign van make it
clear that progress is his middle name
political and civic progress that is
because the slogan certainly isn't
referring to creative progress back in
1955 mayor red thomas has his campaign
car blare the exact same slogan his
predecessor almost certainly followed
exactly the same script if you're paying
enough attention you might notice that
the two campaigns match each other word
for word but subsequent viewings give
you more time to appreciate the layered
ironies at play another favorite both
mayoral candidates are incumbents their
campaigns are promoting change as the
reason to keep on re-electing the same
guy
there's been plenty of nostalgia for the
80s over the past decade just as the 70s
and 80s had plenty of similar nostalgia
for the 50s back to the future was part
of that wistful cultural wave and the
set design proves it once upon a time
hill valley had more civic pride and
less vandalism the movie's view of this
nostalgia is nuanced however and it
doesn't hesitate to skewer exactly this
kind of longing for the past in back to
the future we see that the 50s were far
from innocent after all both goldie
wilson and the band playing the school
dance get racist slurs thrown at them
just for existing the hill valley of
1955 may not have had an adult movie
theater in the town square but it still
had rapists and peeping toms compared
with all that marty's fantasy of a night
away at the lake with the steady
girlfriend seems positively wholesome
even the most basic bits of nostalgia
get subtly taken to task here idealized
family dinners as soon as they get the
chance lorraine's family is thrilled to
watch tv while they're eating just like
the mcflies in the 80s
life imitates art so when an
unrecognizable vessel crashes into your
barn and a mysterious figure in a
bizarre full bodysuit emerges you might
well think aliens are responsible
especially if it's 1955 and you're a kid
with a collection of comic books books
movies tv comics these things are just
part of how we relate to the world
around us back to the future knows this
and leans into it one of biff's pals has
the gimmick of always wearing a pair of
red and blue 3d glasses around a nod to
the 50s craze for 3d which would
eventually return in marty's 80s and
again without glasses in the futuristic
2015 it's just one of several ways the
film shows that the more things change
the more they stay the same
however the best bit of meta-fictional
overlap in back to the future comes when
marty hooks up his camcorder to doc's
1955 tv to show him the footage taken
right before marty's desperate escape
through time
as marty and doc rewind and fast forward
to get to the parts they need in the
tape they're duplicating the time travel
process in their own way moving
backwards and forwards through marty's
future historical record
throughout back to the future marty
always seems to have the same problem
he's constantly late of course it
doesn't help that all the clocks and
doc's workshop are set to the wrong time
but those clocks have nothing to do with
him lingering at the dance when he knows
he has to make it to the clock tower on
time priorities marty we all like johnny
be good but you don't want to get stuck
in 1955
of course the ongoing detail of marty's
lateness gets a satisfying and briefly
bittersweet twist when marty finally
thinks to arrive somewhere early it's so
he can save doc's life marty giving
himself 10 additional minutes to get to
the mall parking lot is an excellent end
to his character arc in the first film
he may be late for everything else even
his own future but when his best
friend's life is at stake he's able to
step up and work past his most
unfortunate habit
when it comes to time nobody has any
business criticizing dr emmett brown he
invented the flux capacitor and
conquered the laws of physics while
everyone else is still frustrated about
daylight savings time however there's
one specific detail that it doesn't take
a doctorate to notice thanks to the save
the clock tower campaign marty knows the
exact time and date that the hill valley
landmark will be struck by lightning
sort of he knows the day hour and minute
but most lightning strikes are over the
same second they began marty has to hit
doc brown's wire at the exact right
moment and he has no idea which moment
that might be as doc pointed out earlier
there are a lot of fiddly little details
that have to be worked out exactly right
for marty to be able to make it back to
1985 but this one seems more impossible
than the rest it's a good thing that
once doc comes back from the far off
year of 2015 he's got a more reliable
trash based fuel source
at first glance marty mcfly and his dad
don't seem to have much in common after
encountering them both in 1955 even doc
brown can't quite believe that the two
are related
that's not true of course considering
that the whole plot of the film centers
around marty being george and lorraine's
biological son it's concrete proof of
the mcfly bloodline but it's not exactly
necessary against all odds the film
makes it clear that george and marty
actually have quite a lot in common
right down to their body language
even more meaningfully the two share
some identical anxieties about rejection
neither one of them can initially work
up the courage to submit their creative
work to a publisher or label that might
turn it down thankfully all the
father-son parallels get a heartwarming
payoff in the film's final act marty
helps george find his courage and win
over lorraine and seeing his father
stand up for himself gives him the
motivation he needs to take over for
marv and barry and lose himself in the
music and when marty gets gawked at by a
bunch of 50s teens and teachers who
can't believe what they're hearing it
turns out that he can take rejection
pretty gracefully after all
kids and their parents have always
clashed over music the art form might
change over time but once our tastes are
fixed they often stay the same sooner or
later we're all bound to get confused by
the latest hits needless to say marty
experiences this phenomenon firsthand
when he plays an 80s style guitar solo
for a baffled 50's crowd i guess you
guys aren't ready for that yet
but your kids are gonna love it
that's not the only time back to the
future shows older generations suffering
when their kids crank up the volume on
the newest hits when marty dons his
hazmat suit to scare the 1955 version of
his dad into asking out lorraine he amps
up the weirdness factor by blasting
george with a few seconds of eddie van
halen cranked up to 10.
george writhes in agony as he's
literally tortured by marty's taste in
music he doesn't get it but his son sure
does
george mcfly's burgeoning career as a
novelist is the perfect cherry on top of
his happier better adjusted life in the
altered 1985. if you take a good look at
the cover of a match made in space you
might notice that it bears a resemblance
to those of real life science fiction
author robert a heimlich connections
between george and heinlein are likely
anyway he's one of the authors george
would have absolutely read growing up
considering that the teenage george was
ready to skip the big dance so he could
watch science fiction theater although
george doesn't know it his own life
winds up being like something out of a
certain hindland story and not just
because he's living in a science fiction
movie himself heinlein's short story all
you zombies deals with how time travel
paradoxes could lead to a person
becoming several of their own ancestors
for example in a decidedly less
family-friendly version of back to the
future we could see that happening to
marty too that's not the only hindland
story that echoes marty's journey though
heinlen's novel time enough for love
tackles multiple kinds of incest in a
science fiction setting including a
romance between a mother and her son
awkward doesn't even begin to cover it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]